in der Region Hannover wird der Müll auf
mehreren großen Deponien sortiert und
gelagert aber Müll ist nicht gleich Müll
weil derzeit überall Brennstoff
gebraucht wird ist Altholz plötzlich
sehr gefragt und teuer dieser
Entwicklung wurde hier in der Zentrale
der abfallbetriebe allerdings komplett
verpennt wenn dies Management da nicht
vernünftig arbeitet und der Bürger muss
das nachher ausbaden finde ich nicht gut
ja katastrophal würde ich sagen das
verstehe ich überhaupt nicht muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen ich meine die sind ja
geschult und die sollten das ja wissen
wie das funktioniert und dann denke ich
mir dann muss man auch seine seine
Arbeit machen im Jahr 2020 schließt der
abfallbetrieb der Region Hannover ein
Vertrag über die Entsorgung von Altholz
20 Euro pro Tonne musste abfallbetrieb
zahlen damit ein anderes Unternehmen das
Zeug entsorgt inzwischen aber ist
Altholz begehrt statt 20 Euro pro Tonne
fürs vernichten zu bezahlen könnte man
jetzt bis zu 70 Euro pro Tonne einnehmen
denn in Zeiten der Energiekrise sind die
Bretter und Balken ein wertvoller
Brennstoff der Skandal in Hannover hat
man vergessen den alten bezahlvertrag zu
kündigen und das sogar zweimal
menschliches Versagen jedenfalls eine
abenteuerliche Panne man legt sich sowas
in die Wiedervorlage und hat eigentlich
immer weiß wann sowas fällig ist solche
Verträge von jemandem der dafür Geld
kriegt erwartet man schon dass er weiß
was was kostet und und wie man das
managed also das schon enttäuschend in
der Zentrale der abfallbetriebe macht
man gar nicht erst den Versuch das
Altholz Debakel klein zu reden
schriftlich erklärt der Geschäftsführer
für diesen Fehler entschuldige ich mich
daraus werden wir Konsequenzen ziehen
damit künftig ein derartiger Fehler
vermieden wird
aber die Gelder sind weg und nun
kündigen die abfallbetriebe fürs nächste
Jahr auch noch eine Erhöhung der
Müllgebühren an also ich finde das
beschissen dass sie das vergessen haben
zu kündigen und wir dadurch eventuell
eine müllgebührenerhöhung bekommen
natürlich ist es wieder das was beim
kleinen Bürger hängen bleibt würde ich
so sagen es ist wieder Umlagen die auf
uns zukommen mehr Kosten die auf uns
zukommen als hätten wir nicht schon
genug in der Energiekrise zu tragen eine
Wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaft soll
jetzt klären wie es überhaupt zu dem
Fehler kommen konnte Anfang Oktober wird
man dann wissen was die altholzpanne den
Gebührenzahler unterm Strich genau
kosten wird womöglich Millionen